this is non brewed condiment its water
ethanoic acid plus a few colorings and
flavorings and in almost all the chip
shops up and down Britain this is the
vinegar you'll get the counter and in
the modern world it has some advantages
it can be made for concentrate which is
fine provided the owner of the chip shop
actually remembers to dilute it that
that went wrong a couple of times it's
also halal
because there isn't a tiny amount of
alcohol in it that brewing regular
vinegar causes and some brands of it are
actually gluten-free which regular malt
biddinger most definitely isn't I've
seen the sold as a premium as
gluten-free vinegar but none of those
are the reason that it's caught on there
are claims that it started in the
temperance movement the people who are
against alcohol in the late 19th and
early 20th centuries but I can't find a
reliable source for that sauce oh yeah I
can't find a reliable Authority for that
the reason is chucking some chemicals
together is significantly cheaper than
actually brewing vinegar this stuff's
been around for a long time there's a
reference to it in a hundred-year-old
report from Her Majesty's inspector of
foods now legally it can't be described
as vinegar Trading Standards local
government agencies that enforce food
laws are really clear on that it cannot
be put in additional little bottles that
people associate with vinegar except
every chip shop up and down the country
doesn't care and Trading Standards well
they could go into every chip shop in
the country and get an easy prosecution
but they don't they've got better things
sitting like tracking down food that
will actually injure or harm you and
it's not like they'd see any of the
money from fines anyway that's not how
it works and most people don't know this
isn't vinegar and well those of us who
do know actually don't care it's not
like margarine and butter where the
chemical makeup and health effects are
actually different it's just a slightly
different taste and slightly different
makeup but no one cares no one Minds up
and down the country everyone agrees
it's fine
this is vinegar so here's my question
does it matter